you'll be in the documentary it's kind
of shitty I don't I've said this before
I don't and I bought into this when we
watched he's he the worst person in that
dark any documentarian I don't trust I
don't trust any documentary and I bought
into this and this is why because you
can make me think whatever you want me
to think with hundreds of hours of
footage that you added into two hours of
whatever you want it to be in in this
case seven hours of whatever you want it
to be yes you got to get your point
across from seven years of footage yeah
you cut into seven hours of course I'm
gonna believe whatever you want me to
believe there is something about this
you had a joke early on about this I
don't know
documentaries no no no no there is a no
no it was a it was about like the 10
cents a day kids oh yeah about how like
why don't you just they're like starving
and it's like you're standing right next
to starving kid like why don't you just
feed them yeah something like that like
a certain point in like are they devoid
of like human responsibility for one
another like if you're doing a
documentary right you're still a human
being right and you still have a
responsibility that people around you
right we just allowed him four months
maybe years to film all these people
that he knew were doing horribly illegal
[ __ ] and he didn't in any way step in
because he was a documentarian I don't
understand why they make like if you're
if you know a murder is gonna happen
right and you don't do anything can you
say oh no I'm a documentarian yeah
that's true there is some kind of thing
if they're actively breaking the law
report it yeah you are complicit I think
that's the term yeah yeah not to play
devil's advocate I think you know so I
can understand to have I think if you
see someone breaking the law you have to
report it as a documentarian I think he
saw them breaking the law what did he
see he saw them so he saw them breeding
the Cubs they're not allowed to breed
the Cubs he saw them we saw them breed
the clubs there's number one doing meth
he must have seen in people how to see
him do the meth
yeah I don't know what what is that
because I was gonna say human meth
probably isn't illegal but buying it is
illegal I mean he saw him basically like
capturing people like he he knew the
other guys weren't gay he knew they were
taking advantage of I don't know if it's
illegal do that kind of stuff but it is
unethical to know that [ __ ] is going on
and the whole time go I'm a prophet all
for this you got to be a scumbag bro
like you're not trying to save people
you don't care about [ __ ] animals
you're doing this because you're like I
can profit off this and I can make
millions of dollars potentially you know
who's probably the biggest insight into
what a documentarian really is what the
reality show guy who want to do the Joe
exotica reality show because remember
that guy who I actually thought was full
of [ __ ] as I was watching but I think an
insight is when he was like Joe exotic
wanted me to to do his internet show if
I can do a reality show on him and I was
like yeah fine I'll do your little
piddly ass internet show yeah I own all
this who cares and you look at him like
oh you're like you're an [ __ ] yeah
you're a [ __ ] leech yeah you're a net
and you're like judging this guy and
you're just gonna profit off of him and
exploit him you're an [ __ ]
that might be an insight into a
documentaries mindset a bit which is
like all right you're a [ __ ] idiot
yeah they're both equally bad yeah like
the the the guy who's doing the
documented Kirkman I think his name was
right
yeah and this document I just don't know
where the ethics come in because I'm
fascinated by a documentary I loved it
so I play a part in this yeah like I
can't go the drug trade is [ __ ] up and
I sit back and be hittin the weed yeah
cuz I know who dies for me to get high
right everybody's smoking weed right now
unless you get in your ship from the
government and even then I'm sure
there's some way that like government is
involved in the drug trade or cartel
[ __ ] probably right there has to be some
kind of you know field analyst with that
we're complicit we're complicit so it's
easy for me to point the finger even
though I'm the reason why that guy's
making it because you can make money off
a guy like me yeah go mark do you think
it's different for journalists this is a
thing that journalists they have lived
like the code of journalistic integrity
yeah we're like they're taking pictures
of starving kids in Africa and they
don't give them any food they can't feed
them like National Geographic like
they're doing these crazy shifts and
they can't entertain you have to be a
complete bona fide psychopath like when
I watch these these these documentaries
on Discovery Channel and it shows the
polar
they're slowly dying and you just
videotaping this [ __ ] see you're
like not allowed to help I think but I
don't know why come on be not against
the law it's some code or something it
can't be illegal to be a doc you know
what that is that's them trying to carve
out their immoral life into a moral
Mithen the morality we all live in I'm
not allowed to help
says who [ __ ] the Guru go to
jail for feeding a starving kid nobody
in their right mind would send someone
to jail for feeding a starving kid yeah
that's a great point they're trying to
give themselves an out they're trying to
give themselves excuse me can't help all
these people are broke
so let's carve out a little place where
it's like well what we do is cool making
money off of them nothing but there's a
code of ethics that you can't help them
we would love to but you can't they're
probably gonna say this I'll cost
they're gonna go if I make this
documentary yeah it's gonna reach so
many people who are then going to donate
money yeah and by donating money will
help way more of these you know what I
would say that is cool that's a great
point well you could also do is take the
proceeds from your documentary and
donate it to them in addition to
whatever aid they get so would you do
that now we're getting to this tricky
thing where it's like dis capitalism
helped more people you know in the long
run where it's like if we incentivize
people with financial gain do more
people actually get help so I'm gonna
incentivize you to make this documentary
with financial gain you can become a
millionaire officer but you know what if
it's popular yeah people are gonna
donate tons of money to the starving
camp it's a tricky thing and I and
that's why I'm trying to bring it up and
just trying to get to the bottom of it
it's like what are the ethics of making
a documentary about some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
I've always thought this about vice vice
is talking all these like terrorist
leaders and [ __ ] like that right like
they sit down to have these
documentaries where they're like hey we
talked to an Isis leader in a cave in
Afghanistan so [ __ ] where that
is a dude I mean you [ __ ] hipster
would you save sides your head and your
koi fish tattoo keep in mind you're not
getting that meeting for free oh yeah
you think that they get
meaning for free you think it's
Afghanistan knows what vice is yeah no
you're coming to them with the bag and
we'll give you 50 grand cash if you let
us talk to one of your leaders what do
you think that money is going you think
that money's going to to what to buy
some kites for the great display was
build a school no that's going to bombs
to blow [ __ ] up yo I never
trust advice ever they always acted like
they were above journalists and like
more pure you're a billion dollar
corporation what's the name bill device
great point lot sometimes you hide in
plain sight
[ __ ] great point so what are the
ethics mark you look like you're looking
this up right now
yeah well this reminds me of a story
there's this famous photographer Kevin
Carter you ever heard this good now so
he took this famous picture of this
starving girl with a vulture behind her
I want a Pulitzer Prize like 1993 and
then after coming back from Nairobi
where it took this picture
killed himself because he was so like
depressed and like sad that he couldn't
do anything to help well he could go to
the vulture you know how easy it is to
get a bird away you couldn't do that
that's against journalistic integrity
this [ __ ] Matt Barnes to Kobe Paul
fake what what are the ethics man I
really why do we never question it why
do we see these documentaries like son
you remember that show we would always
watch um intervention yeah intervene
just falling around this [ __ ] run
around shooting methanol and sucking
dick you know you're right yeah and
there's a producer and it can't make
sure you get the can't right make sure
you get sweetheart could you stop
injecting just give us a second so we
can set the shot immediately can you
shoot up again because we didn't get it
clean that time don't worry we'll pay
for it just sure there's a lot of noise
in the background if you could just do
that again
either were the needles the shot mostly
is more important but what are the
[ __ ] ethnics man like is information
more valuable dude do we just do we just
taste we basically sit back and go these
people don't need to subscribe to the
morality the rest of humanity does
because they're giving us information
that we would not have without that goes
out to the masses and then the masses
can do something
I think the way they rationalize it
would be it's it's unethical for me to
intervene in any way for good or for bad
my job is to report on to actual things
that but again a woman is about to get
eaten by a vulture you got the picture
now do something instead of just killing
yourself yeah son I mean what a kook
thing I don't why can't you intervene I
don't under oh wait a minute cuz you can
intervene in the negative way you could
intervene in a negative and - this might
be it journalists have immunity in war
zones not complete immunity but they can
go to the bad guys they can go to the
good guys whoever the bad guys or good
guys are we don't know right but they
can go around on both sides and
generally speaking they're taken care of
right they're like hey I'm a journalist
I'm not doing anything for any I'm just
here to documents going on they're not
killed once they start intervening their
protection is out the window
hmm now when we're going to some tribal
warfare zone and [ __ ] the Congo and
the journalist is just there to ask
questions they got a kidnapped the
journalist cuz they go the last one that
came here he intervened when some girl
was getting her arm chopped off for
stealing a diamond so you might be here
to intervene as well or he's feeding our
enemies to go [ __ ] yourself you're not
getting anything out of me maybe I'll
show you whatever
so maybe the honorable thing for a
journalist to do is protect other
journalists by not intervening that's
interesting it doesn't I don't think it
applies to ever like a vulture eating a
[ __ ]
I mean it's a girl yeah I gotta keep
that same energy up
what anybody that sentence at home going
oh you're not gonna call the start
nine-year-old
they mean by vulture Abids are you soft
I say one thing
all right go you're right you yeah you
bring up a valid point
I can't are you saying right now what
you just did I've been hoping my girl
would do for about a year right just
interrupt me and go you're right
[Music]